[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY KELLER: Thank you
guys so much more coming.
My name is Emily, and I am
part of the Google Maps API's
deployment team.
And basically what that means is
that I work with our customers
and users of the
Google Maps APIs
to make sure that they get
the most out of the APIs,
whether that's building
a Store Locator
or doing really heavy
duty analysis on data.
And not only making sure that
they're using them in the best
way they can, but employing
development, best practices,
making sure that
they're not doing
something wrong with them, or
making efficient use of them.
And so we're going to touch
on all those areas today.
Let me grab my clicker.
So first of all, I
don't know if you've
been to some of the
other GO sessions today,
but we'll talk a
little bit about what
are the Google Maps APIs,
especially the web services.
So a lot of people
think of Google Maps,
and I think of like looking
at a physical virtual map.
But we're going to talk
about what's beyond the map.
And we're going to
talk about why that
matters for your businesses.
We'll talk about a
little bit the things
that you can do with the
APIs with the web services.
And then we'll go over
the cloud consoles.
So the APIs are part
of the cloud consoles.
If you've been to
console.developers.google.com
and use the API
projects, they're
right there at your fingertips.
So we'll actually
go in and show you
how to get started using them.
And then we'll go over those
development best practices.
So a little bit nitty gritty.
How to use them in the
most efficient way, some
of the things to
watch out for while
you're developing using them.
So first, what are
the Web Service APIs?
Specifically, there
are HTTP services
that you can use to
actually request data
from Google's enormous
pool of geo data.
Whether it's
directions from point A
to point B, or information
about a place--
maybe like the opening hours of
a Starbucks across the street--
or the elevation of a certain
point above sea level.
It's basically a
way for developers
to access and use that rich
contextual location data.
And I personally am kind
of like a Google Maps nerd.
Because I just think
they're really cool.
So when I got the opportunity
to join this team about a year
and a half ago, I really
enjoy developing using them.
Because when you're
using a product that
uses the Google Maps APIs, you
already know how to use it,
right?
Who in this room uses the
Google Maps consumer products
like the website or the
iOS or Android apps?
How many of you came here
using that in some form?
Either the Google Maps like
actual app, or Uber or Lyft?
Probably everyone.
I did.
So that's something that
I think is really cool.
You don't think about how to
get from point A to point B.
And you don't think
is this wrong?
When you look up a location
on Google Maps, you trust it.
What's the stat here?
Two million apps and sites
that use Google Maps APIs.
They are one of the most
widely used APIs out there.
Over a billion developers
on a monthly basis use
the Google Maps APIs.
And they're really easy to use.
They're easy to start using.
It will literally
take 10 minutes
from creating a project to
starting to actually request
that data from Google.
And like I said,
users trust the data.
So you don't think oh,
this is probably wrong.
Or you don't open the
Google Maps app or Uber,
and expect that map to not
work or not up to date.
They're really
comprehensive in that way.
So now why are you here?
You're here for using
cloud and cloud products
to enrich your business.
So what are some of
the ways that you
can use this location data
to actually get value and add
that value to your business?
How can you use it to enable
your location strategy?
We have so much data that
can provide context and allow
you to basically create
new business models
around this type of data.
Sorry, my earrings are
hitting my microphone.
So let's go into some
kind of high level ways
that you can use these Google
Maps web services to enrich
your businesses.
Location intelligence.
So show of hands.
How many of you have been
to some of the geo sessions
earlier today?
All right.
That's actually
great, because this
may be the first time
you're seeing this.
We've been talking a lot
about location intelligence.
Location intelligence
is really just
using location data, both just
point data and context data,
to draw insights into the
physical world around you
and how it's laid out,
how it's changing,
and how that relates
to the business data
that you already have.
How many of you have
businesses that sell something?
I know that some
of you are just not
raising your hands, because
we all sell stuff, right?
Whether it's services or goods,
everybody sells something.
And when you're selling
something, especially
e-commerce, you're
taking in massive amounts
of location data already.
You're taking in addresses that
can be used to provide context
around analytics.
So just as an example,
if I'm in e-commerce,
let's say that I'm amazon.com.
Or let's say that
I'm a smaller bakery
shop that sells
donuts and coffee,
and I have riders deliver them
to people on their commutes
in New York City.
I take in those addresses
where those people are ordering
donuts and coffee, and
if I can translate that
into coordinate data in a
usable fashion and analyze it,
I can really draw powerful
insights into maybe where
I can plan business expansion.
Or where I have the
most profitable markets.
Or maybe where I have
gaps in my service.
You can draw really powerful
analytics around that.
Or maybe where I need
to advertise more.
That's something
that's applicable
across all industries.
Risk analysis.
So just as another example,
if I'm an insurance company,
take in address data
every time a user
purchases a policy from me.
And that address data
can really tell me
a lot about the kind of policy
that I should write for them.
What are my riskiest zip codes?
Are users more likely to
get into traffic accidents
if they live within a certain
proximity of a traffic circle
or freeway?
How about just one neighborhood
or another neighborhood?
Are they riskier?
It's already there.
The data is already there.
And using the Google
Maps Web Services
to provide that
location context,
can allow you to draw
those new insights.
Resource accessibility.
This is a huge one.
It's kind of like a weird
thing to be passionate about.
There's 23 million people in the
US that live in food deserts.
This is like trivia.
Anyone here know what
a food desert is?
You in the middle.
AUDIENCE: It's
places, in the city
usually, where there
are not good choices
to buy groceries that are of
high quality and [INAUDIBLE].
EMILY KELLER: Exactly.
So it's limited or no
access to healthy food
choices like fresh
fruits and vegetables.
And you're right, it's
usually in cities.
And you think well, it's so
easy to find places and cities.
It's really a public
health problem.
It's a real big problem.
And if you're a nonprofit
and you can actually
use location data, especially
from the Places API--
which actually there's
a talk that's entirely
focused on the
Places API tomorrow--
but you can basically
use point data
to gather really rich context.
What is that point?
Is it a business?
Is a home?
Let's say it's a grocery store.
What are the reviews
on that grocery store?
What are imagery that we can
gather from that grocery store.
Are there fresh fruits and
vegetables available there?
You can actually use
this contextual data
to identify resource
accessibility in certain areas.
And so not only grocery
stores, but this
can apply to hospitals.
Let's say something a little
bit less public health related.
Gyms.
If there's no gym
within a 10 mile radius,
you've got like a serious
business opportunity there.
The resource accessibility
is a really huge thing
that can be done using this
contextual location data.
Move and optimization.
So when I think of
move and optimization,
I think of it as kind of
like the next generation
of navigation.
Everybody knows you can
navigate from point A
to point B using a bunch of
different mapping services.
But we're not just
talking about navigation,
we're talking
about real analysis
around the movement of
objects in the world.
Businesses all have assets
that they care about,
whether it's people--
Accenture is here
at this conference.
I think there's like
500,000 people that
worked for Accenture.
Those are their assets.
They need to know
how they're moving
around the country
and the world.
If you're a trucking
company, you
need to know how those
trucks are moving,
and the efficiency of them.
Our recent geo
talk, we just talked
about smart vending machines.
We have this massive internet
of things that basically allows
us to know where things
are in the physical world
and how they're moving.
And that can be really
useful in drawing insights
into your business operations.
We'll talk about
the APIs that you
can use to enable these things.
And tomorrow there is
also a talk specifically
on the geolocation API.
This is really cool, kind of
like maybe lesser known API
that Google has.
It allows you to pinpoint
the exact location of Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth enabled devices,
like my Fitness tracker here
that don't actually
have GPS capability.
And it uses triangulation using
Wi-Fi towers and Mac addresses.
But you can basically track
the location of anything.
Like anything in the world.
So real time navigation.
Getting from point A to
point B is really important.
But now we can do
that even better.
We have predictive
traffic time that
allows you to pinpoint to
within a 10 minute window when
your pizza is going to arrive.
Probably five minutes
or something like that.
Bit if you're moving a person
from Williamsburg to Manhattan,
or whether you're
moving diamonds
from San Francisco to
Seattle, it's really important
to make sure that you're taking
into account road conditions,
and you're taking
into account traffic,
into account maybe
anticipated volume of those
kind of routing problems.
Basically like the
minutes that you
can save using that
predictive traffic
time, historical and current,
translate into real dollars.
And routing algorithms.
So if you've heard of
the Distance Matrix API--
I always refer to the traveling
salesman problem here.
How can I move my
items from point A
to point B to point C to point
D, maybe not in that order,
but in the most optimized way?
So you can use the
Distance Matrix
API to really
optimize the movement
of your items across the world.
Location intelligence.
This is something also that
can apply to every industry.
Location intelligence
can address the better
understanding of the daily
changes and activities
in our physical world.
Oh, this went back.
Whoops.
Connected devices.
This is where we should be.
We've been talking about
connected devices a lot,
the Internet of Things.
Everything is connected now.
You probably have five items
on your person right now
that have some kind of
internet connection,
or are able to basically be
tracked in the real world.
Actually, I was just talking
to someone who's here.
There you are.
So we were just talking
about this exact to use case.
Geo Fencing.
If you knew that you
had a certain volume
of potential customers at
a certain time of day that
were within a
geographic area of,
let's say your physical store,
you can tailor your advertising
and marketing to them, you can
tailor your staffing needs,
you can tailor your
inventory even,
just by tracking the location
of either devices or people
to within a very, very
high degree of accuracy.
The Internet of Things.
I think that the prediction is--
I'm going to look
at this prediction.
I want this number to be right.
40 billion connected
devices by the year 2020.
That is a huge amount of
connected devices moving
around the world in real
time that you can use
to drive business analytics.
So cross industry--
and I know there's
people here from so many
different industries--
these things apply to everybody.
It's absolutely
across industries.
Location data can
drive business value,
it can create new
business models,
it can optimize your
user experience,
and it can create real
rich local experiences.
So we're going to
go into exactly
which APIs you may want to
use for certain use cases.
And we're going to go
into how you can actually
get started using these APIs.
So I'm going to jump
on my computer here.
How many of you have used
the developer's console?
Good amount of you?
So this may be a
little redundant.
But we won't spend
too much time on it.
Can you switch over to the--
there we go.
So using your Gmail
account, you can log
into the developers console.
And if you're an organization
that already leverages
the cloud APIs or just
different cloud infrastructure,
you already have one
of these projects.
Like I said, the
Google Maps APIs
are just another capability
within this cloud console.
So I don't have a
project because I just
created this account.
And I'm going to open
a donut shop somewhere
because I like donuts.
So I'm going to call this
project Emily likes donuts.
And I don't want emails.
So while this project
is being created,
you can really leverage
these in your organization
best by building them within--
I don't know why that happened.
Well that's OK, because I
have another account that
already has a project.
That's OK.
So you create a project
and it works obviously.
So then it's going to
take two seconds for us
to start using the
Maps APIs here.
I've created a project,
and I'm an API manager.
I'm basically going
to go and enable
the APIs that I want to use.
This is why we have a
video of the same thing.
So let's just go back
to the presentation.
I'll just use the video.
See, this is why I
need a joke handy.
I have it recorded in a video.
Let's just go back
to the presentation.
I'm just going to show you
guys a video of the same thing
instead of doing it live.
[LAUGHTER] It's good.
No big deal.
We don't need to show that.
I'll just talk about it.
So most of you have been
into the cloud console.
So unnecessary demonstration.
You can enable the
Maps APIs the same way
you enable any of the
cloud APIs, Vision API,
things like that.
So to talk through my
donut shop example,
I would enable the
geocoding API and I
would enable the Places API.
It's OK.
Don't worry about it.
Thanks, though.
It's fine.
I was just going to show
you guys how to do it.
The point is, it
takes five minutes.
If you're getting excited
about using location
data in your
businesses, that's good,
because you can leave
here and you can
start doing it in five minutes.
You basically just
generate something
called an API key,
which you then
use to sign your web service
requests to all of the Google
Maps APIs.
And this API key is kind of
your signature as a developer.
It tells us who you are, it
allows you to actually track
your web service requests.
So when I gather my
address data from my users
that already order
donuts from my shop,
I would use the geocoding API
to translate that address data
into coordinates, which would
then allow me to again pinpoint
my most lucrative areas.
And maybe I want to open
up a storefront there.
So in addition to finding
out the densest customer
population, I'm also going
to use the Places API, which
provides that really rich
context data to locate
existing donut shops or bakeries
or coffee shops in that area.
And maybe I want to
find a place that
is within a certain distance
of my loyal customer base
to build a donut shop.
But I wanted to be at least half
a mile from the next bakery.
I don't want too much
competition right off the bat.
I'm a starving baker.
Is that an oxymoron?
A starving baker?
So those two APIs, I could
start requesting that data
right away.
If I have my data stored
in the cloud console,
I can build things
that are integrated
there to translate
that data right away
and start doing that analysis
to open my donut shop.
And then as I'm
growing organically,
or as I'm making those requests,
as I'm building those services,
I can track the usage in
the APIs console as well.
So it's really it's
the same place.
It's the same kind of
functionality as tracking
your cloud APIs.
And it's very easy to use.
We're going to skip all those.
So as mentioned, if you
already use the cloud APIs,
it's very easy to start
using the Maps APIs.
So you can start thinking
about your location strategy.
You can start messing
around with your data
and building that location
context on top of your existing
business data.
You can start trying
to find new ways
to draw parallels between
your business and location.
So here is going to be
the meat and potatoes.
And before we start out
with the best practices,
I basically want to
tell you not to worry.
Much like learning
long division,
and then being handed
a TI 89, you're
really not going to have to
do these in your development.
There are client libraries
that are out there
in a few different
languages that
allow you to kind of implement
these best practices when
you're developing with
the Google Maps APIs
without having to
think about it much.
So we're going to go over them
so that you have this deeper
knowledge and you can be a pro.
But we'll talk about
the client libraries
and how you can use those
to wipe your hands of it,
and know that Google is
helping you along the way.
API key security.
So we didn't get to
generate an API key.
But when you do generate an API
key, the default security on it
is none, which is OK.
Especially if you're
just messing around,
if you're using it
within your organization,
if you're making
requests to analyze data,
you're probably not going to
have anyone steal your key.
In my time at Google, I think
I've seen this happen one time.
And it really doesn't
matter that much,
because you can
create a new project
and you can create a new key.
But it can happen.
And like I said, your
key is your signature.
So think of it like you
see these weird charges
on your credit
card or something.
You're like oh, I should
probably cancel this credit
card and get a new one.
Your API key is
something that it
is a best practice to secure.
We love security at Google.
So we do give you opportunity
to secure your API key.
When you create a
key, like I mentioned,
in the credential section
of the developers console,
you can name it if you want.
So I named it Emily's
super secure key.
And you have the opportunity
to restrict it to HTTP refer.
So for example, if
I'm building my Emily
likes donuts.com, where
users can actually
go order donuts from my shop.
And I plan on using the
JavaScript API, which
is one of our web APIs in
that website to build a Store
Locator, I might want
to restrict this key
to only being able to be used
from Emily like donuts.com.
And that way my competitor
Bethany Likes Donuts.com
can't find my key and my front
end code and start using it,
and using up my free quota
as a standard plan developer.
I can also restrict
it to IP addresses.
So for example, my server,
if I'm doing a data analysis,
and I want to restrict it
to certain IP addresses.
And then I can also
restrict it to Android apps
and iOS apps using
those app IDs.
So this is definitely a best
practice that we'd recommend.
Rate limiting.
This is something that
comes up all the time.
Rate limiting in
general is a principle
that is existing in a
lot of different APIs.
It's essentially just
limiting the number
of requests that you can make
in a certain number of time
to each API.
For the Google Maps
APIs, in general
that's queries per second.
In some of the APIs, such
as the Distance Matrix API,
it can get a little
bit more complicated.
So when you make a request
to the Distance Matrix API,
you actually specify multiple
origins and destinations
that you might be going to.
And so in that
situation, it's actually
kind of based on number of
things you request per second.
And you can find more
details on that kind of thing
in our developer documentation.
We'll just in general talk
about queries per second.
And it's 50 as a
default right now.
And so businesses say all the
time why do you have this?
If you want to be
infinitely scalable,
why do we have to adhere
to this kind of thing?
And our response is
usually let's work together
to figure out what
your expected QPS is.
But it is really important
to have that expectation.
Basically, having
that QPS allows
us to do capacity
planning for one thing.
But it protects you and
it protects your end users
against something either--
I was going to say how many
of you have developed bugs.
But you're not like super
engaged with the hand raising,
and I know you
would all lie to me.
Everybody has developed
a bug at some point.
And so you don't want
a bug in your system--
let's say we didn't
have rate limits--
to use a million queries per
second, and your app goes down,
and Google server goes down,
and the internet breaks.
And you're sitting at
your computer like oops.
So that's kind of
the main thing.
It protects end users
across the board.
And it protects
your application.
So if you have billing
enabled, if you're
an up and running business
and you do pay for some usage,
and then some kind of bug or
maybe a malicious user that
has taken your API key
makes a ton of requests,
we would figure it out.
We would do all the
Google-y things.
We would forgive the
usage or something.
But you get that charge and
you're like what is that?
So having QPS limits
actually prevents
some of those harry
situations from happening.
I'll just leave this
here for a second.
So this is impossible because
we do have rate limits.
So you can't use 87 billion
geocodes in five seconds.
But we don't want
this to happen.
We don't want you to
spit out your cereal.
Error handling.
So again, when we talk
about the client libraries
that you can use to develop
using the Web Service APIs,
a lot of these things
are handled for you.
But it's good to
know about them.
So when you make requests to the
Google Maps web service APIs,
you get something
called a status code.
And there's a bunch of these.
They're kind of varied per API.
Some of them have
unique status codes.
And we're going to talk
about the ones that
are pretty universal across
all of the Google Maps APIs.
So there are some statuses
that you want to see.
This is usually the
first thing you'd
check for when you get your
response from the APIs.
An OK status is
what you want it.
It's thumbs up.
It means that you
made a request that
was recognized by our back
end, and we provide you
with data per your request.
It's good.
Zero results is still fine.
It means that you provided
us with a request that
was legitimate, and we
didn't find anything.
And then we told you we
So for example, if
I tried to geocode
the Flintstones address, which
is 301 Cobblestone Way I think.
My memory betrays me.
But I probably would
get zero results,
or I'd be very surprised
that we found it somewhere.
So next, statuses where you
want to retry the request.
Over query limit has a lot to do
with what we just talked about.
So if you make too many requests
within a certain time period,
you're going to get this
over query limit response.
Like I said, usually
this means QPS.
You've gone over
a certain number
of queries within a second.
But it can mean queries per day.
So as a standard plan, which
means basically a free user,
non enterprise user, you have
a limited number of requests
that you can make for
free any given day.
So if you've
exceeded that, you'll
get this over query
limit response.
In that situation,
you would basically
want to retry the request
after a period of time
using exponential back off.
Basically you keep retrying
that request over an increasing
period of time until you
get a successful response.
For over query limit, if you
don't get a successful response
after retrying,
it probably means
you hit that QPD limit,
queries per day limit,
rather than the queries
per second limit.
Unknown error is
another response
where you do want
to use exponential
back off to retry a request.
Unknown error usually happens
because there was some kind
of server error on our side.
Sometimes that happens due to
a high traffic at the time.
So if you use
exponential back off
you maybe limit the
number of times you retry.
But you'll eventually get
an OK response hopefully.
Finally, we have statuses
where you don't want to retry.
Something was wrong,
and retrying won't help.
Request denied.
So I mentioned API key security.
If Bethany Likes Donuts.com
tries to use my API key,
she's going to get a
request denied error.
Or if I use an API
key from a server,
from an IP address that
hasn't been whitelisted,
like my domain
was whitelisted, I
would get a request
denied error.
Similarly, if I try to make
a request to the places API,
and I don't put an API
key in, it's denied.
It's basically something
with your credentials
that is incorrect or
missing in this situation.
Invalid request is also
something where you don't
want to retry the request.
It means that
there was something
wrong with either
the formatting,
one of the required
parameters was missing.
So for example, if I try to geo
code something like a bicycle.
Not an address.
If I don't put an address or
a lat long, or a place ID,
it's going to be like,
what you're talking about?
So invalid request means
that there was something
wrong with the request.
In these situations,
you should log them
and you should kind of try
to identify the root cause.
Some of them you can
programmatically fix.
These are just things
where you definitely
don't want to retry them.
There's actually great
video on our developer site.
I believe it's right on the
landing page for the geocoding
API.
But it talks about error
handling and exponential
back off, specifically in
context of the geocoding API.
But as mentioned, these
status codes are really pretty
universal to all of
the web service API*s.
Mobile apps.
So when you think
of mobile apps,
you probably think of developing
in native Android or iOS.
We do have Android and
iOS SDKs that you can use
to develop on those platforms.
But in some situations,
it's better for you
to use the web service APIs.
Maybe if there is a
feature or a piece
of data that's not available
through the native APIs.
Or if your use case
just lends itself more
to making web service requests.
Maybe you want to do
more with the data
before you return it to
the user's mobile phone.
We generally don't recommend
embedding your API key
and making those requests
directly from a mobile app.
The best practice here is to
proxy those requests through
a server, and then using
our client libraries--
which we'll go over soon--
build a server side
application that
basically takes in their
request from their mobile phone,
queries to Google Maps
APIs, gets back the data,
does whatever you
want with it, and then
returns it back to the user.
So as mentioned, the Maps
API share the cloud platform.
And the best way to do
this is through App Engine,
Compute Engine.
It allows you to really use
those services in the most
integrated way possible.
Now these famed
client libraries.
We're finally here.
I'm giving you the TI 89.
No more long division.
Most of the things that
we just talked about
are handled through
these client libraries.
So these are open sourced.
They're on GitHub.
You can use them to develop
that server application
to either do the heavy duty
data analysis, leverage location
intelligence, or to build the
server side application that's
going to take in those mobile
app requests and proxy them.
They wrap the functionality
of the Maps APIs.
And so they're
consistently updated
as we come out with new
features in the APIs
to include that functionality.
And as mentioned, they implement
those best practices for you.
So for example, rate
limiting is handled inside
of those client libraries.
And you can set specific
QPS's that you want to use.
They're available in multiple
languages, which is great for--
probably developers here
are like those quants
who's developed in 14
different languages.
But I'm certainly not
so I appreciate the fact
that the languages
are kind of varied,
so that I don't
have to learn go,
even though everybody loves go.
It's really great
because it allows
you to develop in the IDE
of your choice, and in a way
that you'll be comfortable
basically building
and leveraging those APIs.
As mentioned, they take care
of rate limiting for you.
So there's a default of 50
queries per second built
into those client libraries.
But there is a way for
you to set that yourself.
It will take care of
exponential back off
and error handling for you.
It'll handle signing your
request with your API key
so that it's not in
your client code.
POJO, so basically when you
make a request to the Maps APIs,
you get returned an
XML or a JSON object.
But using the Java
client library,
it'll actually translate
those into usable objects.
And the client library
support, both asynchronous
and asynchronous API calling,
depending on your needs.
Cool, so I haven't been to
the code labs area here yet.
But there is a code lab
on the client libraries.
It's actually hosted
by Brett Morgan,
whose team built the library.
So very knowledgeable.
Like I said, you can leave here
and you can in five minutes
start using the APIs.
Probably worth it to
go to this code lab
if you're interested
in doing that
and get some hands on help
with building these server side
applications using
those cloud libraries.
And if you don't do it,
it's available online.
You can do it at home.
These code labs really valuable.
So we've gone over
a lot of stuff.
Pretty nitty gritty
stuff at some points.
But you're probably at
this point like great.
Where can I find all
this stuff online?
You can.
The geo developer's log
is a really great way
to stay up to date with
these specific things.
The client libraries, I
think are relatively new.
But there would have been a blog
post telling you all about them
and how great they are.
We have across the
maps API organization,
people contribute to this blog.
And so it's just a really
great place to keep in touch.
Our developer site is
also a really great place
to get technical
documentation, sample code.
You can probably build
an entire application
just by copying and pasting
stuff from the developer site.
(WHISPERS) That's what I do.
Like I mentioned,
so the home page
will give you latest
updates, videos, tutorials.
That video on the geo
coding API error handling
was on the developer site.
This is just the
default place that you
should go to find out
information about the Google
Maps APIs.
The beta program.
So this is another thing
that is relatively new,
but a really cool way
to be the first person
to be using certain features.
And you can actually
not only use
new features in
the beta program,
you can directly influence
how we build the APIs.
So this is another nerd moment
for me, but I work at Google.
So that's not a good example.
I can influence stuff I guess.
But if I did, it's
really cool to be
able to just be
like I contributed
to this new awesome API.
This is my feedback that
has resulted in this result,
this feature that
I'm able to use now.
It's a really great way to just
be really directly connected
with us.
Awesome.
So I leave you with that.
Get excited about
using location data.
It's very easy to do.
There are a million
possibilities of the ways
that you can use it to
enrich your business.
And you can get started today.
Awesome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]